this will be the second time that jose
archite is facing the baltimore orioles
in his career and he's also second start
in a row against these baltimore orioles
mullins coming off a three-hit effort
last night roswell behind the plate
single becomes a double and
there goes
cedric mullins with a lead off home run
and the birds got
one nothing
well we talked about being a fly ball
pitcher and if you like to pitch up in
the zone against a fastball hitter
cedric seems to have been hitting
everything that's one of the
consequences
bottom of the first inning travis lakin
senior on the mound for baltimore and
what is expected to be a bullpen day for
the orioles
2-1 right back at you
happy birthday to you
lakins with the flip to first astros
retired into the second with the orioles
on top one nothing
we chase something here oh two man that
fastball misses high and away
we're gonna have a little mound visit
here from the training staff with jose
or kitty on the mound you can see our
kitty calling maldonado out to the mound
well that's going to be it that's really
disappointing for a lot of reasons where
kitty getting the start tonight
obviously an abbreviated start and now
andre scrub comes on
ground ball towards the hole correa
backhands long throw bounces in there
and yuli makes the pick on the second
short hop mike alfranco retired another
fine play from deep in the hole by
correa
the 1-0
antoro hits it in the air shallow right
center racing in mullins also coming
over hayes and hayes comes in front of
mullins makes the catch corey attacks
coming home the throat of the plate not
nearly in time correa scores standing up
toro sacrifice fly ties it at one
there's the action pitch and it's ball
four
third walk of the inning and they're
loaded for michael brantley because the
trainer is coming out
okay and so
maybe a physical problem just kind of
squeezing his forearm
and brandon is going to take the
baseball from travis lakins
what in the world is going on tonight
oh my
gosh so adam who pitched last night
seldom appears off balance
by ball left field
hard to tell with that sky ball but it's
caught on left field mckenna right there
it was not a home run ladies and
gentlemen so they leave bloated and
we're tied at one
and fall into center field coming on
straw still coming on a sliding catch by
monstro throw to first not quite in time
straw has really picked up things
defensively as the year has gone along
at fine play in center
very nice play in center
oh
what a beautiful pitch he did go around
man
castle trying to claim he checked but
scrub comes back to pick up a strikeout
but he's still learning how to hit at
this level
and he chases again went right back but
again how do you do that you get ahead
you trust your stuff and very hard to do
that when you're behind in the count
and he just goes right up the ladder
there he goes
swing of the miss throw to second and he
guns them down
well yeah you want to look at that one
perfect throw the last one was high this
one right on the money gets him in the
back swing drive deep left center field
toward the wall and off the fence
maldonado heading for second base the
throw into second is
in time
raley would like to pick up a strikeout
here with two strikes the astros will
bring the infield in close with runners
on second and third
swing and a miss a big strikeout raley
gets their best hitter cedric mullins
for out number two
austin hayes the batter he's over two
with a ground out and a fly out
trying to make some adjustments and
there's your fastball there you go
that could drive in two
here comes wins with the second run and
delivering with two outs austin hayes
puts the orioles on top three to one
with a two-run single just inside out
stays inside of it does an over swing
and gets it over correa's head orioles
had a couple of runs here's abraham toro
he's driven in the lone run for the
astros tonight
looking to snap an over 11 right here
there's a line drive base hit that'll
tie the game up at three abraham toro
has driven in all three runs
as carlos correa crosses the plate
and it's a 3-3 game well the bull coming
up big with the base hit going the other
way with this fastball away that was a
nice piece of hitting
up out over the
plate and just shoots it the other way
we're gonna have to get an exit velocity
on his bat tosses
swing and a foul tip caught by martin
maldonado nice pitch by garza
swing and a miss nice inning by ralph
garza jr as maldonado flips it to yuli
for the put out
back-to-back strikeouts in a perfect one
two three six
cedric usually handles the fastball
pretty well
drive base hit that'll put the orioles
ahead in the corner
mullins around first into second with a
go-ahead double yeah we got a number
about a week ago that
and one of the highest batting averages
on 95 plus
fastballs and there was one
and all he did was ping it i mean talk
about a short stroke
2-2 fastball let's hit hard
way back and it's gone that's the one
he's been waiting for
hit it a long way last time not as far
this time but he pulls it to right
center and anthony santander
with an add-on run it's 5-3
the ball was blistered
the pitch
swing and a high fly ball deep left
center straw is back at the wall he
jumps and he missed it it's off the wall
bouncing into center field mckenna
scores liba right behind him who is
right behind him all three are home
michael franco breaks it wide open he
had all these guys with this is when
verlander and cole were there did he get
at it did he get it out of here way back
and left and this one is gone
believe so yep
touch them all ramon arreas third homer
of the
year and the orioles add a couple more
four for five night with a homer two
rbis score to run
tucker gets a hold of one
but that should end it
austin hayes
puts it away and the orioles have a 13-3
win